كان في قبول بالمهانه كافي ضعف يقولون نعم
هذه بها خسائر وتضحيات ايه وهي متى كانت
كان الوصول الى الاهداف العظيمه بلا خسائر
وبلا تضحيه حرب غير متكافئه اندلعت دامت
لاربعه ايام متصله رفضها المجتمع الدولي
وكل الدول العربيه قصف شرس بالطائره
والبوارج تم تدمير البنيه التحتيه للجيش
العراقي والسبب غير واضح هل هو من اجل
التغطيه على فضيحه جنسيه لرئيس امريكا ام
من اجل نزع سلاح العراق الموجود في خيال
الامريكان فقط لماذا قامت امريكا بقصف
العراق عام 98 ولماذا اصرت على موقفها رغم
رفض المجتمع الدولي لتلك الحرب الظالمه
وما هي الفضيحه الجنسيه التي دفع العراق
ثمنها غدرا لتعرف اجابه كل تلك الاسئله
تابع الفيديو للنهايه
فضيحه جنسيه تربك الحسابات
في عام
1998 انتشرت فضيحه جنسيه للرئيس الامريكي
بيل كلينتون وفضحت علاقته الجنسيه بمتدربه
في البيت الابيض
تدعمت الفضيحه
الى قضيه راي عام في الولايات المتحده بل
قل قضيه راي عام في العالم كله خضعتون
للمحاكمه وخرجت اراء كثيره تطالب بعزله من
منصبه رئيس اقوى دوله في العالم في ازمه
كبيره فكيف يخرج منها كما تخرج الشعره من
العجين
كبش الفداء لم يجد كلينتون اي حل للحفاظ
على منصبه سوى الهاء الشعب الامريكي بقضيه
كبرى ويحبذ لو كانت حربا يشعر فيها
الامريكانو بالخطر لابد من كبش في داء
ينقذه من ورطته ولكن من يكون هنا لاحق
امام كلينتون عدو امريكا الدائم عراق صدام
وهنا كان المخرج ولابد لكنتون حينها من
وجود مرافق معه ليدعمه او يمد له يده
ليخرج من ورطته ووجد ضالته في ابن امريكا
المدلل والمطيع بريطانيا ورئيس وزرائها
انذاك
اتفق كلانتا وبلار على العراق ووقفت في
خطاب امام العالم واعلن العراق يمتلك
اسلحه نوويه وبيولوجيه ويسعى الامتلاك
سلاح النووي متطور ومحرم دوليا ليهدد به
جيرانه ومصالحنا في المنطقه على العراق
التخلص من تلك الاسلحه فورا ليخرج صدام
حسين ويعلن امام العالم قائلا العراق لا
يمتلك اي اسلحه دمار شامل او اسلحه محرمه
دوليه كل ما يقال عنا في هذا المجال هو
افتراء لا اساس له من الصحه يبدو ان الخطه
الامريكيه الخبيثه في طريقها للنجاح فقد
نسي العالم فضيحه كلينتون الجنسيه واصبح
الحديث عن اسلحه العراق وتهديدها هو حديث
الساعه فكيف تطورت الاحداث
ارسال الجواسيس
خرج بالكلينتون مطالبا العراق باثبات حسن
نيته قائلا لستم من يقرر انكم تمتلكون
اسلحه دمار شامل ام لا ولا حتى نحن عليكم
الخضوع لبعثه التفتيش عن اسلحه الدمار
الشامل التابعه للامم المتحده وهي من
سيقرر حقيقه امتلاككم لاسلحه محرمه دوليه
ام لا كان العراق لا يزال منهكا من حرب
الكويت كما ان العقوبه الاقتصاديه التي
وقعتها عليه واشنطن كانت قد انهكت اقتصاده
اكثر فاكثر كل تلك الظروف اضعفت العراق
وارغمت صدام على قبول تفتيش بعثه الامم
المتحده في البدايه تعاونت الحكومه
العراقيه مع البعثه وكانت لجان التفتيش
تتحرك بكل حريه وكيف ما شاءت ولكن فجاه
طردت الحكومه العراقيه بعثه التفتيش
وارسلت شكوى للامم المتحده قالت فيها ان
اللجنه التف
تيش مهي
كله في الامريكيه وتتنصت على كل المكالمات
العراقيه الهامه لصالح واشنطن وهذا يخترق
مبدا سياده الدوله ما اجبر الحكومه على
طرد البعثه لانها خرجت عن صميم عملها فكيف
ردت امريكا
ذريعه على طبق من ذهب جاء طرد العراق
لبعثه التفتيش بمثابه فرصه ذهبيه لشن
الحرب ورغم رفض المجتمع الدولي واعتراض
الدول العربيه اصرت على موقفه حاولت بغداد
تجنب الحرب وتحدثت مع الصين وروسيا وفرنسا
من اجل التدخل واحباط المخطط الامريكي
الخبيث ولكن دون جدوى وبدا ضرب العراق
عمليه ثعلب الصحراء
تحركت البوارج وحاملات الطائره الامريكيه
نحو العراق وفي السادس عشر من ديسمبر عام
98 بدا القصف العسكري بنحو 400 صاروخ من
نوع توماهوك وطائرات اثنين وخمسين
الامريكيه والتي تحمل قنابل تزين سبعه
اطنان استمر القصف لاربعه ايام متصله تم
استهداف المطارات والمواقع الاستراتيجيه
العراقيه حتى ان العراقيين قد جعلوا من
انفسهم دروعا بشريه وضحوا بارواحهم من اجل
حمايه منشاتهم الهامه ولكن لم يكن ذلك
كافيا فقد تم تدمير اكثر من 50% من البنيه
التحتيه من المنشات العراقيه الهامه تدخلت
روسيا وفرنسا وبعض الدول وقاموا باعتراضات
دوليه على تلك الحرب غير المتكافئه حتى
توقف القصف بينما قال مراقبون الدوليون ان
القصف كان سيستمر حتى استسلام صدام حسين
وتنحيه عن السلطه لولا الاعتراضات الدوليه
وعدم تاييد المجتمع الدولي لتلك الحرب
والسؤال لكم متابعينا هل حقا قام كلينتون
بتلك العمليه ضد العراق فقط للتغطيه على
فضيحته الجنسيه ام ان اضعاف الجيش العراقي
وتدميره كان هدفا اساسيا لوشنطن قام به
كلينتون بتخطيط من الاداره الامريكيه
[موسيقى]